good morning John it is Tuesday no
private morning Hank it's a reunion
video are you weird we both kind of look
tan no but I think it's guys at the bad
lighting so a very special question
Tuesday Jonathan 9 years that we've been
making for this video I wanted to do a
question Tuesday in which we tell people
things they still don't know about I
asked Twitter and here are some of the
questions that I received who had more
girlfriends in elementary through high
school me yes I had more girlfriends in
elementary school though I will say that
killed it in elementary school oh you
didn't I had long-term relationships in
elementary school that's right I was
just like hop hop hop hop hop I held so
many hands did you when you were kids
did you know what you wanted to be when
you grew up I thought that I wanted to
be an oceanographer but but I turns out
that I don't like boats
I didn't want to be a writer when I was
a kid but I never thought it was a
realistic job I thought it was like
wanting to be an astronaut or something
what is the pettiest thing you still
argue about we did have an argument
yesterday about which part of the human
body would take the longest to eat know
I feel like the argument was about which
part of the human body would make the
largest contiguous state it's all Betty
until you you're a cannibal and then if
suddenly the very very Rio and asks does
John cast movies know who has bigger
ears asks Sarah hmm no no my ears are
this big
my ears are this big let's measure with
the Goonies like right here okay I made
a little mark all right there we go I
have the bigger ears but I'm older yeah
they keep growing keep getting bigger
Henry's right behind the camera and I
just asked him if the video was funny
and he said no so I'm concerned so hey
can you do something funny
all right video is funny again bubble
baths soothing relaxation or boiling
cesspool Oh soiling sets no no no no
we're about to have the pettiest
argument we've ever had
dads are wonderful it feels like like
putting my entire body on the every
other part of my body Ainsley asks
nerdfighter emoji there's there's one
that I use is it this one yet the lady
who's going like that hey what is your
20 year goal oh but I'm 55 I want to
still have a colon how is Dave green
fines doing good whenever I'm like how
you doing Dave's just like live on the
trail t-d mmm
he does say that it's weird I don't
think it's that weird I think it's cool
I keep thinking it's FTD which is the
flower delivery service have you ever
seen each other poop henry is lively
laughing again probably when he a Hank
was like nobody right souls yes it's
been a while rapidfire what's your
favorite musical Hamilton what if every
public the Second Coming by WB Yeats
what book have you reread more than any
other pool actually probably Hatchett by
gary paulsen if you go on my child
last question Hank what do you think of
as your biggest accomplishment you do
that it makes shadow animals on my body
is this your biggest accomplishment
right now this making a terrible duck
that kisses me on the cheek
my biggest professional accomplishment
is vlogbrothers my biggest personal
accomplishment is uh behind the camera
you picked Henry no I mean I've I'm also
very proud of arbiters of course but
among that in there I think my greatest
accomplishment is having made the
Internet's most viewed video of a goat
giving birth is the thing that I did
that's incredible no one can take that
away from me I'll see you on Friday
Tuesday so bad at days yeah I know I
know
it's uh your problem for all whole lives